he's the best voice actor we've ever
really had on television or movies in
America
he's also what does he do he's a
director he's an actor he's a producer
he's in he's a singer he's only
ballerina is the only area of show
business he has not yet Oscar hosts he
stars in the notion not while he's on
the news
Showtime I can say that well miniseries
the loudest voice they never used to let
me say that you must have a lot of pull
and his latest album is once in a while
Seth MacFarlane everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come up and get dressed the show's first
of all you're doing more Orville's yes
we are
[Applause]
thank you I need a show like the Orville
I really did you know what I made you do
Captain Kirk embrittle yes first yes yep
yep was there any way okay so that's
good so I'm going to talk about the
debate format because yeah they were
tweeting last night I mean texting to
each other and also i retweeted you i've
mazing we were thinking the same thing a
couple of times first of all the
audience well you need an audience the
audience has to [ __ ] go and like now
right it's the worst it's it's a bad
it's it's a bad for a million reasons of
all it's you know the number of
candidates in this in this particular
situation is obviously through the roof
so every second counts and when you have
to you know I have a wonderful acting
coach named Eric forum Erin McPherson
I'll call him out who said that there
was a time when not everything got a
standing ovation right now every show
you go to everything gets a standing
ovation all the time did you stand when
stuff came out but every single you know
tagline gets this one well because well
they said it and it starts to eat up
time well I I don't think this can be a
serious country until we make the media
the news media yeah a loss leader again
like they used to be where they didn't
have to make a profit because I don't
know who set this up and I love MSNBC
well I got it or the DNC that kind of
stops at the NCD they could have they
could have set it up in a much more
mature way they like this Thunderdome
like what's this thing where how do you
break in just start talking right
there's no rule just interrupt and be
louder than the next guy if you're
talking over quits first game a chicken
this is not the way to pick a president
no and and it turns the candidates into
a sideshow right everybody is granting
everybody's putting on a show for the
audience and the on show is not invited
to think for themselves
no because they feel like they're
watching Mike and Molly and all these
all these humble brags about you know my
but everything is personal like is
everything as a personal yeah yeah and
everything has to build into this anger
thing and out doing virtually everybody
else you think you don't like kids in
cages I don't like it even more than
this guy I got a say and I loved I
warmed up to to Camilla hugely
last I thought she did fantastic but the
one but one candidate who seemed immune
to that was Buddha judge yeah was the
one candidate who seemed like he was if
the audience whether the audience was
there or not you would have gotten the
same performance yes I think that's true
and I we both had that same feeling that
he could be the guy he'd to me and again
this is so interesting about age you can
be old and dumb and you he was the
youngest one on this stage and I thought
he looked the most mature he looked the
most real yeah he looked like he didn't
have to think you know he's the smartest
kid in the class he didn't have to we're
not just saying that cuz we're gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he is like this more this guy every time
you know the only thing I ever wanted
out of politics was for the president to
be smarter than me right
you